welcome to this video playing Turk stir
from the US and yeah we know no more mr.
slow guy I'm playing quickly yep normal
stuffy in the vegan our game b3m ok the
setup is very solid for what he's got a
very young stable very stable center I'm
trying to check maybe go for that severe
decision why did he take that um anyway
what do I go for here f five probably
mmm 95 you will probably take or f5 here
ok I'm not quite sure yet what is he
going to do maybe it's going to regroup
there too and be one or something maybe
night two is six this is definitely
looking ok I can also regroup my bishop
they're very difficult for why to do
anything I can at least go for at five I
only went rookie aids because I wanted
to I wanted to get the night over oh I'm
happily taking this now he is going to
get that pawn structure before them can
always highly ticked away with the night
and it's better night over to f6 we want
to treat check oh yes that's cool let's
do that
it's still of course quite dry but maybe
I have some ideas I can can go all the
way yeah but whatever you want with the
pond so let's see how to do this can i
maybe provoked some more weaknesses
they're not quite sure 96 night before
I'm happy to enter the night against
bishop because the position is so so I'm
so static the night is really okay here
nothing's happening there can do
something on the Kings side probably not
probably not g6 h5 something like that
hmm why is he going there I don't know
anyway it's probably still a draw can I
know h5 know some kind of have to always
have to check for tricks there ok so
maybe go back with or to e6 if he goes
on to ok now the Queen the King site is
shut down this is this is jin general
pretty nice for me because i don't have
to worry about it and now i'm attacking
maybe I can do night c5 at some point
and irritated 94 the second opponent
game worth playing hmm 94 takes pawn
takes king of for now don't think that's
leading to much night c5 is probably a
draw ok
trying again to provoke some weaknesses
there I'm happy that you put the power
on g5 so it's going back to this
approach and now here anything that I
can do here at night to f7 is not
helping might be four is also not
helping maybe I can go a 65 or something
like that hmm entering their doesn't
doesn't help either if I go some some 65
know what does it tell it's probably
really just a draw maybe if I can get
wait if I can get the night to e6 and
they came to see Five somehow and then
c6 probably not on probably not going to
happen and maybe this and now King c5 is
this an idea I just have to make sure
that that is not that I'm not running
into some kind of wacky check made now
this is interesting check then King
takes but no Kris moving c6 Bishop e3
mate this is a this is funny ok so I'm
going back with a king
so now here and 95 it seems that he has
to and trade now and king cakes and then
something with c6 at the end sg5 power
is a problem and I think and c6 and I
think this is a problem here so d for
it's not working okay it might be a draw
yes it might be a draw and here takes
King e4c for King d6 backings if I've
just draw King Arthur King spoke in your
[ __ ] before King g5 King b3 King
f-16c for be five ticks ticks it's
probably still a drawing hi morning
check before I didn't think about that
move ok
what's up ah don't Ave to what the heck
i miscounted oh what a bad game okay i
miscounted this resigns how did I screw
this up I mean okay i tried around here
nothing Kevin it was kind of okay what
did I do wrong here check huh that uses
to to this be sure before stuff I didn't
think about that at all King c5 is a
drawn check I didn't think about before
I know I was just thinking about c4 I
mean it's just one temple but it is the
one temple yeah that was bad job
probably you cannot do something in his
endgame 94 winning hey why didn't I do
that why didn't I play 94 in this
position am I completely blind I mean
this this move look to be yet but why
are not doing this and he resigned
simply oh wow I really having what am i
doing at the moment you I'm really in
bad shape check yeah g5 is not really a
good move but it doesn't seem to doesn't
seem to be okay if I go king is seven
again I'm winning according to the
engine because it cannot defend both
once yeah i'm just playing badly what
can I do but can I lose just playing
rattling okay I was still trying to play
em play quickly and I'm winning with 94
the whole time when we're not playing
this move am I completely do to god he
just resigns after then why am I not
playing this ah difficult I don't know
what I'm doing at the moment again 94 is
winning the whole time it wins again it
wins it's also totally obvious now that
i see it of chest because this is just
this is just losing flat away I'm just
winning the pawns yeah I was shuffling
shuffling and shuffling and I never play
90 form chan yeah yeah it's a draw of
course check and I I screw it up with DJ
exam this is the draw I don't know it
was just just really really bad if it
tries that now I'm winning with b5 so
we're really cute motif and ce4 no no no
I'm winning this is the kind of thing
that I that I saw I didn't see before it
all this is really bad okay thanks for
watching